I will say this bad hobbies you have a
alcohol addiction you're into you know
illegal drugs and stuff like that that's
something you need to be smart about
alright that's it's not good for you to
begin but never mind what she wants or
what's good for her it's not good for
you to begin with but at the end of the
day women will try to bethe ties you
they go that they'll put guys through
unknowingly they don't do this
intentionally they'll unknowingly put
men through a precise and progressive
set of steps and series of steps known
as beta ties ation by a thousand
concessions and it starts out with
something simple like oh do you really
need to go hunting with the guys and you
still go anyway and then it turns into
something like you abandoned hunting you
know with the guys or going to the even
if you don't hunt maybe you go to the
shoot the clay targets do some skeet
trap for example and you abandoned that
because she doesn't like that because
you know you've got a gun in the house
which should be locked in a safe by the
way but you know she doesn't like that
because of whatever value she might have
one of the things that's always bothered
me is winner is whenever somebody tries
to impose their beliefs and values not
always in recent history but like when I
was in my 20s people would always try to
impose their beliefs and values on you
well you can't do that or you should
stop doing that or done it and often men
are quite happy to abandon their here
men are quite happy to abandon their
passions to placate women but when
people start to impose their beliefs
sometimes it's your hobbies sometimes
it's certain friends sometimes it's
religious belief but whatever if people
try to tell you what to do because it's
in their belief system that's usually
the first sign it's time to say sayonara
and goodbye to that individual in your
life that's a part of you I'm never ever
ever going to give up going to rallies
exotic car meets Hank you know like
hanging out with the boys driving fast
it's never gonna happen
it's it's part of me I enjoy hanging out
with those men I enjoy the camaraderie I
enjoy poking fun each others poking fun
each other's cars poking fun each others
driving skills you know having coffee
sitting doesn't have a lunch and all
that stuff that those are things that I
enjoy I enjoy hanging out with my
brothers from the rule 0 game right you
know I have an opportunity to hop on
that when I'm not busy on a Saturday so
there's there's parts of your lives that
should be non-negotiable as men they
should not abandon that you should not
walk away from just because a chick says
oh I I don't agree with your hobby of
hunting I don't care I don't agree with
your vegan lifestyle if you want to eat
plants and vegetables go for it I'm not
gonna shove a steak in your face like
it's it's really as simple as that men
will never do that well it's not that
likely I mean some some men will have to
enforce boundaries with women because
they've got bad habits ie going out
clubbing with promiscuous women you know
if they want to be in a relationship and
you've decided to do that and they still
continue that you need to enforce that
boundary you know it's an obvious one
that is different from going out with
your friends for a few days on a cabin
hunting trip or going into the back
country one of the things that I used to
like to do that a girlfriend that I used
to date a while back tried to impose
some restrictions on is I'd go to
Algonquin Park and if you're not
familiar just google it very quickly
it's let me see if I pull up real quick
pics I got my screen share here right
here about here nope
come on image so this is what you get
when you go to one of these backcountry
places it's real real nice stuff right
you know something like this this is
this is one of the bigger lookout spots
so you can go look that up but they got
a lot of portage trails and canoe routes
and all kinds of stuff throughout all
the lake system there it's not a
particularly comfortable place to be if
I'm being honest there are bears there
because I can kill and eat you Wolf's
probably a mountain lion some you know
those cats they're for sure but it
wasn't because the safety it was because
it would take time away from her and
that was a non-negotiable for me I mean
I would do that with a bunch of my
friends now over the years I mean we've
been doing this since our 20s
and over the years I've still be the one
that's still insisting on wanted to go
and do these trips but slowly but surely
all these guys as they get wiped up or
as they have kids they're no longer able
to go and do the annual summer trip for
like four or five days in the
backcountry which is a shame because
it's it's one of the best bonding
moments you can have with other men men
or tribal men need to be around other
men men needs to do things with other
men you know and when we get together
they just sit around and Yap right but
when men get together we like to get
together and go out and do something
usually something to challenge us
usually something to make fun of each
other but there's some kind of a
camaraderie that exists in that instance
one of the one of the differences that
you'll notice between men and women is
when men hang out together we're usually
together side by side and and this is a
function of you know throughout history
if we were out hunting together I got
somebody here beside me we see a
mastodon out there and we check an
amount looking at behind the bushes your
friends not sitting across the table
talking yeah he's to your left or you
know to your left or to your right
because you're having a conversation
you're getting ready to I am down and
spear this bad boy right but when women
get together they just sit around and
talk so you just sit around a table or
circle or across from each other so
you'll notice the big big differences
between the way men and women interact
and if if women become aware to the fact
that it's good that men have hobbies
that it's good that men have friends
that allow them to do productive things
and get them out of the house and allow
them to have something to do aside from
her because what what most guys end up
doing is they end up making her the
hobby they end up making her the focus
of it all and book one rational male one
of the biggest takeaways from that was a
woman should only ever be a compliment
to your life and ever the focus but far
too many men are all too happy to
abandon their friendships their hobbies
their interests because she said that
he's not allowed to do it any
more how many guys you guys know that
we're fit strong muscular men you know
before they got involved with a woman
got wiped up or something like that and
a few years down the road they turned
into a fat slob right this is not
uncommon I've seen a lot of dudes a lot
of friends am i nice to hang out with
you know we go to the gym and as soon as
they get involved with a woman in their
life they they just don't look the same
you know they pack on 30 pounds
sometimes 100 pounds maybe even more and
they just give up they don't they don't
put any effort into their appearance and
not only is that not good for them from
the self care perspective but what these
men fail to realize is you cannot relax
as a guy women can relax in a long-term
relationship okay
I mean all they're really supposed to do
is maintain their level of attraction
but men need to continue to chase
excellence and part of chasing
excellence means maintaining competency
skills it means making sure that you
know you have that like if you're a
hunter and you're hanging out with your
friends behind or you fish you can still
get the fish right that's why I keep the
boat so you can still get the fish so
you have to make sure that you're able
to demonstrate that and be able to bring
home the bacon because that that kind of
stuff matters but far too many out you
know I got rid of the boat because you
know I got this instead and she wanted
to get a minivan so now we have a
minivan and that's what we do you know
sort of thing or maybe have a camper van
you know camper / minivan but they give
up their personal time with their
friends and it's so unattractive women
guys have no idea how unattractive they
become as a function of saying yes yes
honey yes did you guys ever see that
stand-up comedy here was a Chris Rock or
Chris Tucker I can't remember I was get
the Christmas confused but there's one
stand-up where you know he talks about
just getting a stamp just stamping
everything yes yes yes yes honey can I
yes honey can we yes how do you connect
right let's just stamping everything
without even questioning or saying no
and you have to as a guy be in a
position to say no to women you have to
be able to hold firm you're supposed to
you're a man you're supposed to have a
backbone you're supposed to be able to
say no to her but the problem is is men
we just get beta ties you know we just
get weak
you know we allow it to happen and you
have to you have to be aware that it's
happening but most guys are not aware
they just don't see it
they'd have no idea that it goes down